-Guys, finally, it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ "WeTweet" ♪
♪ "WeTweet" ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you
five different tweets.
We're all gonna vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You have all voting clickers
at your seats.
There you go, yeah.
That looks organized.
Now, look, you could
vote for all of them,
you can vote for none of them,
whatever you want.
And we're gonna see
the results live.
Roots, you have your clickers?
-I got it.
-Tariq, you have your clicker?
-Yeah, I just entered
all my answers.
-No, no, no, no.
You have to wait for the tweets,
then you vote "yes" or "no."
The green or red --
thumbs up or thumbs down.
-Okay, got it.
-Yeah, yeah.
You're pretty good
at this, though.
You've -- You're pretty good.
The last two
you've gotten, right?
-The last two,
I've been super on point, yeah.
-Yeah, alright, here we go.
Alright, so,
whatever tweet gets most likes,
we're gonna tweet it out live
yeah, so that you can all
like it and WeTweet it.
-Aha!
-It's a shared experience.
Alright, are you guys
ready to do this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, here we go.
Alright, our first tweet is...
♪♪
-It's coming in
a little tepid there.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I feel like
everyone voted already,
and there's just a non-reaction
from the audience.
[ Laughter ]
I don't think this bears well.
This one's not going to do it.
But the votes are in.
Let's see the results.
Eww!
[ Sad tuba plays ]
[ As Johnny Carson
This might blank you,
but I only blank when I blank.
-Yeah.
-[ Normal voice ] That might
have been a better tweet.
-Right.
-Yeah, it was
G-rated right there, yeah.
[ As Carson ] Sometimes
I blank this when I blank.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
This next one says...
You can do whatever
you want on this thing.
Just don't put anything on it.
-I like that one.
-Yeah, I feel like
people kind of like it.
I think people are in kind of
a generous mood, too.
That first one
was a little knockout punch.
They're back up.
They're ready to go.
Someone dropped his clicker.
That was bad.
Yeah, alright.
[ Drumroll ]
All right, here we go.
Let's see the results.
Oh, yeah!
-Wow!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Coasters!
Alright, The Coasters!
-♪ Roller coaster ♪
-Alright, how about this next
one here? It says...
♪♪
-That's the one.
-It makes you feel good, too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have a good
feeling about that.
What are we thinking?
You thinking it's 170, 180?
-I'm thinking
at least 170, yeah.
-160.
-160?
-Alright, I'm going to say 180.
-Okay.
-Wow!
-Let's see the results.
[ Drumroll ]
-Whoa-ho-ho!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow!
That was almost
a complete home run.
That one's gonna be the one.
Alright, here we go.
This next one is pretty good,
too. It says...
-Yes.
♪♪
-Yeah, that one got a good
from the audience, as well.
Might be two of them we're
tweeting out.
Alright, let's see the results
right here on that one.
-Yeah.
-No. No. No.
No!
No! Not even close.
It's still "casserole dish."
This last one is...
♪♪
Oh, I'm feeling good about
"casserole dish."
-"Casserole dish" is the one.
-Alright, here we go.
Everyone put your votes in.
Let's see the results.
[ Drumroll ]
Oh, not bad.
♪♪
But it looks like
the winner is number three!
It's "casserole dish"!
[ Dinging ]
Casserole dish!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm going to post this during
the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a WeTweet, and enjoy.